shane bieber on the mound tonight first
time in over three months great to see
tonight he'll make the start for the
indians as they take on the white sox in
game three of this five-game set here at
progressive field
in the air right field routine play for
oscar mercado
one down
and the one-two
swag and a miss he came right back with
it and struck him out
two down
there's a line drive to right and
mercado snares it to retire the side
dylan cease going to the mound for his
31st start that is a full season era up
over four but 212 strikeouts at 156 in
the third
ground ball in the hole nice play by
montana and his spinning throw or bray
couldn't stay on the bag
there he goes
on the ground up the middle this still
could be two tim jabs the bag and throws
for a double
the 2-0
swung on chopped into the shift into
shallow right to make the grab is miller
strong throw
that last one was a good one
that strike three reyes went around on a
sharp breaking slider
and one gone one two
called strike three
a generous strike three dylan will take
it one two count on cesar hernandez and
he got him looking at a fastball
three strikeouts he's retired the first
seven in a row to start the night
swung on a liner caught at the shortstop
position by jose ramirez so three
innings 34 pitches nine up nine down i
mean boy
line drive right field that's gonna get
down for a base hit for owen miller he's
going to turn and burn here's the throw
it's a good one a little offline and
miller's in there safely with a lead off
double
three and two
struck him out of fastball
man outside corner strike three
tossed him a slider and out goes mercado
two down
strike three lead off double and then
he wore black and they were white and he
would always win the fight
trevor stefan 41st appearance of the
year
hey struck him out
of downtown i'll tell you what he's got
a very good arm
pass first base abreu breaks up the
perfect game with a two-strike two out
single in the fourth two and two
that is strike three for dylan cease his
sixth strikeout tonight
we agree with you
jose with a hard turn but he will hold
there goes jose
swinging a miss struck him out throws
not in time stayed on the bag and that
stolen base number 25 for ramirez
3-2 struck him out
police robert yesterday helped the sox
to that division clincher with a solo
homer to lead off the second inning
12-game hit streak with eight extra base
hits in the process that's really
impressive from robert and he cracks
this ball to left center field zimmer
back at the track and the wall and
robert sends it up and out
luis robert
for the second straight day as a home
run in the sox league
one two
towards second that's a nasty hop and a
nifty pick by cesar hernandez
nice
sounds good two down there's strikeout
number nine for dylan cease
this to left in a base hit for tim
anderson so he's got a hit and eight
straight back from the injured list
swing and a miss and moncada has struck
out against all three indians pitchers
tonight
to third base
and ramirez where is it what is
happening
jose ramirez he had the ball and he
couldn't figure out where the ball was i
don't know if it went into his jersey
swing and a miss
oh goodness that goes off of dylan cease
and that's going to be a hit for bradley
zimmer
my goodness well let's hope it's not off
the pitching elbow and it is
hopefully it got a little of the meat
above that elbow and not just all bone
he said come get me
yeah you're gonna you're gonna you're in
pretty much what he's saying is you're
much more valuable to us over these next
three four
weeks than you are tonight ryan burr
will have as much time as he needs to
loosen up not running
and a base hit
he's gonna try to go to third no stops
two and two
tapper back to the mound burr and
collins and nobody made the play and now
they got a chance around third bradley
zimmer's caught in a run down throw to
moncana he is out
bradley zimmer
has been in no man's land a couple of
times as a base runner in this series
and the sox get a donation from
cleveland on the bases
tech swing he went around that strike
three so ryan burr gets the job done
anthony goes second appearance
former outfielder converting to a
pitcher
got him
100 miles an hour and cesar could not
pull the trigger
two two coming
oh he wrapped it around for strike three
that is beautiful from aaron bummer
slowly chop
gonna be a base hit yes it is but harold
he's another guy that gets down the line
very well
[Applause]
johan double clutch to second throw to
first and he's got the out there
swinging to miss strike three that's
three sliders from aaron bummer
he breaks in strike three down goes
mercado one two
strike three baffling breaking ball
zimmer goes down and kimbrell has two
quick strikeouts two and two
struck him out there's the first one two
three with three strikeouts for craig
kimbrell he's on for the 65th time
shooting for save number 35 and 41
opportunities 2-1 to bradley
on the ground second base cesar
hernandez and the sox have won it
one to nothing luis robert a home run
but if you're looking at what the
bullpen
wants to be in the postseason it's what
happened tonight at progressive field
[Music]